hallo normaler weg hallo liebsten
normalen weg das baue ich mich halt so
hoch du fragst du was noch
so kann ich dir geben in höhr kommst du
kopf her dass in meine sachen habe ich
finde ich nicht naja du siehst aber
bestimmte einnahmen wenn du dich noch
ein bisschen um guckst ja aber jetzt
sehe ich hier gerade erst mal eisen was
ich kein abbau ich komme zu den und
schlag dich wenn du jetzt nicht sofort
gibt es liegt hier wenn du willst kannst
wo liegt es wohl liegt es dass mit den
schlagen für übrigens eine blöde idee du
hast zwei pfeile im arsch bei mir um
mein gott bitte lass ich einmal ein foto
machen
okay da warte ich wenig wie soja
wartenberg so stehen ja okay jetzt sitzt
bleibt so stehen jetzt gibt es war mir
eine freude mit ihnen
ein gestörter riesig und ich werde hier
so erhöht ist übrigens ich weiß jetzt
auch glaube ich warum die kürbisse auf
hatten und der eine voller rüstung hatte
der die voller rüstung nämlich von dir
gleich weil er weil du gestorben ist und
der die aufgesammelten dann hat er auch
noch der anderen kürbiskopf der dann aus
irgendeinem inventar von uns beiden
daran hast aber irgendwie doch die
rüstung aufgenommen hier habe ich auch
dachte dass die von dem dienst ist von
dem mann geht mir ja wenn du ja kommt so
richtig serie gerne alter muss ich
zugeben kommen macht das ändert sich
aber wenn wir nicht gerade leisen abbau
grad machen ab hier ist noch ein skelett
hat auch wieder meine richtung der alten
skelett
die hülle sieht aber ich bin schon
wieder einmal in unten nach diamanten
suchen einander stadthaus war moment hat
ich vermute da oben sind
das wird dann keine ahnung an sein und
du könntest mir eine spritze gegeben ich
gibt auch zwei wieder mit absinth sonst
muss ich erst mal verdauen
ich glaube nicht dass du das machst baue
ich mir geht selber eine dauert nur
deutlich länger aber jetzt erstmal ein
ofen machen muss und so weiter
ich bin halt an ihr vorbei gelaufen ohne
dich zu schlagen ist das nicht gut ja da
merkst du schon was das für eine
seltenheit ist
als mir in der seele weh ich glaube ich
ich glaube ich auch gleich noch mal
zurück und lag im recht warum bin ich ja
so für ein friedensvertrag
als ich an dir vorbei
so eine ganz schlechte idee weil ich
hier mit schwertern und eisen rüstungen
ausgestattet bin im gegensatz zu dir
ich habe meinen anzug ja ich bin seriös
ich habe eine villiger maske was das
seriöse ihn wieder wettmacht ich habe
einfach eine eisen rüstung das reicht
mir hatte ich kann als theoretisch f3
drücken ohne dass man den sieht dann
kannst du der sogar im single erst
erfolgt verborgen
auf höhe 17 das heißt ihr könnt
diamanten sein und da unten geht
irgendwo die auch noch viel weiter ich
habe ein bisschen überblick verloren
weil ich zu dir zurück gelaufen bin
nun könnte es mir wirklich alle die mir
spitzer gegeben
dann können wir hier auch was endlich
mal mehr abbauen
oh mein gott ist eine menge lava
lapislazuli er also willst du mir eine
spitzhacke geben dann geht alles
schneller
warum denn weil ich mir sonst erst mal
eisen brennen müsste und mir dafür erst
mal eine crafting mensch dann ofen dann
warten bis drei eisen da sie gemacht
sind dann macht das doch warum gibst du
mir das nicht einfach auch mal anhalten
so etwas habe ich dann für einen verein
für einen vorteil dadurch dass ich es
die gäbe ist dass wir schneller
zusammensammeln zusammen was habe ich
davon diese tatsache jedoch es heißt
together show und nicht wir bekriegen
uns nicht angefangen mit ich hab nicht
bekriegen angefangen über einmal du ende
gesetzt die wir dadurch angefangen und
ich hatte sofort wieder so hier
ordentlich wieder gemacht hättest du
mich nicht im nachhinein wirst du nicht
sofort hinter mir her gelaufen das
könnte jetzt auch sagen ja eigentlich
wollte ich dir ja gerade diamanten
schenken als du mich da getötet heißt
aber dass micha getötet
das macht es irgendwie geht können doch
das macht sind besagte ja ich hätte das
eher wieder aufgebaut aber du hast ist
auch da ist mir komplett egal ich würde
eigentlich gerne jetzt einfach weiter
sammeln anstand hier zu warten weil
sonst war hat sich hier halt und macht
nichts aber ich weiß warum das ist kein
sinn hat wenn du da mit mehreren
spitzhacken rumläuft herbst selbst heute
so hat es drei stück habt ihr drei
stücke gehen dann sind wir noch im stein
ich hab dir drei stücke geben egal ich
gehe raus anlass auch dass dinge z bau
nehmen jetzt bin ich erst mal dabei mir
hier eine spitzhacke zu bauen
du hast 100 von verhalten gesehen 100
prozent zuletzt jetzt nicht unter allen
umständen des spitzer geworden
vielleicht solltest du nur lieber mal
nicht dauernd danach denken was ich dir
irgendwie falsch was ich irgendwie
vorwegnehmen könnte sondern mal
zusammenarbeiten
ich wollte doch extra bei ihnen zwei
machen klappt nicht so gut weil ich
denke da kommt etwas warum so von wegen
mein haus das war nicht irgendwann
plötzlich brennt ein haus sondern ich
sag's dir ja ok hat einzig minuten und
greift wenig an sondern töte sehr diese
reserve oder so anders so oder so
angezündet mit tipps tricks auch ein
pfeil und der stifter tödlich da hat es
nach kurths das feld bei facebook hoch
genau jetzt in diesem moment
und wenn ihr dann jetzt gerade
vielleicht das bild angesehen auch bei
facebook wisst ihr genau zu dem
zeitpunkt haben wir aufgehört
gut weg
ich mache mir erst mal meine spitzhacken
bild is on the way
du kannst du bringst deine brüste mal
wieder anziehen wenn du sie mir geben
würde
liegt hier muss die range dichter am
kein platz im inventar dann halt nicht
soll ich das foto post will er weiter
brennen ist oder wo die pfeile marsch
hast wir können sehr beide zusammen
packen
aber das ist zu kompliziert um
mitternacht wäre es dann auch anleihen
management richtig aktiv das ist ein
konkreter ausblick auf die folge warte
wann war das haus anbrennen das reicht
mir ich werde jetzt hier gerne weiter
suchen und ich habe es genau
jetzt da hinten irgendwo weiter ich
glaube nicht ich könnte jetzt so stellen
die lava schubsen
nur dann würde so viel eisen verbrennen
dass wir mal wieder so unnötig das will
ich mal in halle wo sind wir überhaupt
die reingekommen
irgendwo ist loch in der decke oder gibt
es auch in normalen weg hallo normaler
weg gibt einen normalen weg das baut
mich halt so hoch du vergisst nur alles
anstatt dass wir wären schon längst
wieder zu hause und hätten das haus
gebaut also den kanal also wir sind doch
hier war hoch gekommen
hier geht es geht nur mit hoch bauen
sollte es vielleicht eher kurz runter wo
der spring hoch wenn ich dir sage das
einfacher einfach mal springen am besten
wir sind total also schnell sind richtig
richtig schnell wasser und einmal auf
und auf 3 1 zumal ganz einfach mit den
einfachsten aber ich treffe jetzt ein
zufall
das ist der falsche weg
ja wenn ihr so offensichtlich ist ein
gewisser mit in die höhle so weit weg da
kommen wir vielleicht nicht noch mal hin
unternehmen jetzt wenigstens noch mal
doch ich glaube dass der stress mit ihr
habt an häufig werde ich mich meine
würde
das habe ich nicht gesagt dass er
zugesagt
ja aber es entspricht der wahrheit in
freisen mit weil wir das wir brauchen um
im starthaus ordentlich werkzeuge und
alles zu haben für die nächsten gäste
damit die auch ordentliche häuser selber
bauen können für einfach sagen dass wir
nachher die ganze werkzeuge von den
gästen bereichen tun
ja die haben aber nicht mehr so viel
also packt media teile ich glaub's park
hatte auch keine beim zweifel hat sich
die wende an
schon aufgenommen und kev selbst hatte
so war ich das in der kiste gesehen hat
euch zumindest auf den ersten blick
keine gesehen am besten tun etwas rein
und kohle tun wir da rein und ein
bisschen holz und dessen kabel stone
alles was man so am start ein bisschen
braucht fackeln kabel sohn habe auch er
selbst kaum
ich habe unendlich viel kommission
sicher die sohatec ag 16 vorerst den
zins text also wurde das darunter gebaut
da muss ich hier wenigstens keine karte
ist unser hast du deinen diamanten
ich habe keine diamanten das gucke ich
erstmal nach du bist es schon doch noch
nicht wieder zu hause ich seinen namen
wer nur dafür dass vielleicht als der
hat ja irgendwie so dauernd hätte ich
auch als hut verkleidet an das mega
witzig fand als er sich wieder verteilt
hatten ja schon wieder mob discs oder
solches plugin hat das geldwäsche wie
das ist karneval oder wie es gab schon
mal die fasern in china witzbold
verdienen auch seine mutter hühnchen lp
für angemeckert nein
juli wird jemand mir gesagt dass diese
runden höhen aussparungen dass die immer
nur in den slums pons sind ob ich kann
weil ich nicht ist das so schaltet man
in die kommentare schreiben
nicht nur weil lena sagt schreibe es in
die kommentare dann lasst euch nicht
nötigen hier was ich nicht wissen dürft
ihr mir das in die kommentare schreiben
aber macht nicht beikommt kräfte bei der
mag das nicht verraten
fallen die kommentare ich schreibe jetzt
keinen kommentar passt wie hast du dich
so komisch hoch gebaut weil ich bin ja
nicht dann statt die normalen weg zu
gehen kaiserliche mitnehmen ich bin so
fleißig ja das denke ich auch die ganze
die sehen nur als nicht ganz deutlich
wie hoch gehen und dann reisen reisen
oder wollen einfach die rendite komische
gebäude da mit einem gast
das nächste mal bauen das habe ich schon
so empfiehlt mal gesagt wir machen es
nix klettern dann bauglas muss merz
nachfolgerin ich sehe schon dass das
tageslicht oder das nachtlicht zumindest
das in fackeln
aber ich spüre den frischen wind auch
luft ließ sich das spürst du und ich dir
deinen namen
wer bist du nicht oben ja ich versuche
rating wie wege zu gehen aber jetzt dass
ich dachte ich dass es oben her wir sind
wir in so tiefen reingelassen wir waren
unten gerade wieder der höhe 10 oder so
ich bin oben mein licht ist hier schon
fast verloren weg mit kakaobohnen aus
dem spawn allein aus dem wald aus dem
dschungel oder das aber im sport aber
auch welche wir brauchen wir müssen mein
dorf finden
aber bitte bitte stellt
ist alles dunkel und ich sehe hier gar
nichts mehr hasst wie eine kugel shader
installiert ha ha ha ha jo
selbstverständlich erst mal fackeln
gekostet woher jetzt wieder runter jetzt
wieder runter es ist nicht gut
ich wünsche nicht oben
ja aber hier so viel ich muss das eisen
abbauen sie hier oben selbst doch gast
viel eisen so umsehe gerade drin
ich weiß nicht wo wir herkommen nehmen
alles eisen mit erstmal im zweifel
richtung null koordinate laufen
logischerweise tageslicht aber das ist
ja hier hin wenn ich glaube ich so
richtig fetter sie richtig fettes mehr
halte ich weiß nicht wo wir sind
wahrscheinlich ist das ein riesiger
dschungel darauf jetzt zur 0 koordinate
die muss ja logischerweise nach hause
führen alter ist richtig krass viele
höhlen hier so krass viel eisen und ich
muss alles mitnehmen
ja okay so viele minuten haben wir schon
aufgenommen dann genau eine stunde
denn mein neues thema noch meinen folgen
thema das ist ja gerade wo sie absichern
dass keine creeper kommen sorgt beim
papa ich hab sonne sonne sonne schlucht
gefunden wo halter war der große rest so
dass nur zwei statt miteinander
das ist ja voraus sein alter des übels
dich großmann übels ich übelst groß und
12 so groß sind dass aber richtig krank
absolutely ich hoffe ich habe vorhin
überhaupt das eisen eingesammelt weil
ich kandidaten 360 ungefähr 300 300
hier sind super toll was sagt mich noch
falsch das ist nur eine komische stimme
in deinem kopf sah bewerb ich bin jetzt
laufe ich aber raus ob ich hier so viel
kohle und kohle bringt auch xp
ich bin schon level-5 bin beim
hausverwalter die schlucht es gar nicht
so weit weg da kann man dann ja auch
meine expeditionen und muss zur
koordinate f3 laufen also osten kommt
darauf an wo ich bin
gf 380 koordinate laufen weil das bei
der spawn ist beim parkhaus und das ist
00 nein das ist nicht 0 0
wieso lässt sich leicht auf start hin
das ist nicht nur 0
ja aber ungefähr nein auch nicht
ungefähr hättest auf jeden fall 240 beim
spot